Behold.
The foundation of the universe.
The ideas that govern the microscopic world.
It’s quantum field theory time.
This episode was supported by SkillShare.
Hey Crazies.
I know you’ve wanted quantum field theory
for a while now.
Well, it’s finally time, but let’s ease into
this with a closer look at light.
We’ve got two different models for light:
The EM wave model
and the photon particle model.
Both of which seem unconnected.
Spoiler Alert: They’re not.
Having ideas be separate is great when you’re
trying to be practical,
but deeper understanding comes from seeing
how things are the same.
Even though Henry from MinutePhysics has called
me pedantic for this philosophy,
I’m going to stand by it anyway.
Neither of these models is a part of the other.
Like I said, they seem unconnected.
The only possibility is that there’s a deeper
idea that explains both of them.
That deeper idea is the quantum field.
But let’s ask a simpler question first.
What is a field?
I did a video on this before, but that was
back in the early days,
so let’s go over this again.
A field is a quantity or measurement assigned
to all points in space.
That’s it. Nothing more. Nothing less.
But quantities come in many different varieties,
kind of like my clones.
There are scalar quantities, which are just
single numbers.
A scalar field would be something like voltage
or electric potential.
A single number assigned to every point in
space.
There are also vector quantities, which are
numbers with direction.
A vector field would be something like an
electric field.
A number and arrow assigned to every point
in space.
There are even tensor quantities, with many
levels of detail.
A tensor field would be something like the
Riemann spacetime curvature.
A collection of 256 numbers assigned to each
event in spacetime.
Light is called an electromagnetic wave because
it’s a wave in the electromagnetic field.
When I show you a wave like this,
the blue and orange arrows don’t have a
size in space.
Only the white line does.
The arrows are measured in whatever units
are appropriate for the field.
A field that existed before the wave passed
through it.
I’ve always just kept the picture simple
by not showing you the field.
Every field has an equilibrium.
In the middle of empty space with nothing
around,
the equilibrium for the EM field is zero everywhere.
When the light passes through, the field is
disturbed and those numbers change.
After the light passes through, the field
returns to normal.
The point I’m trying to make is that zero-values
don’t mean the field isn’t there.
Zero is still something.
The field is always there.
Well, at least on paper.
The physical existence of a field is still
up for debate.
So is that electromagnetic field a quantum
field?
Eh, not really. At least, not the one I just showed
you.
Oh.
Come to think of it, that electromagnetic
field is actually two fields.
A blue arrow for the electric field and an
orange arrow for the magnetic field.
But when we talk about them, we group them
together as one thing.
You might say we unify them.
That’s what a unified theory is:
Showing that two different things are just
different parts of the same thing.
In this case, the electromagnetic field.
This is a tensor that has electric parts and
magnetic parts.
Instead of having two different vector fields,
we just have one tensor field.
But tensors aren’t always very convenient.
Hmmm, let’s take this one step deeper.
The electric and magnetic vector fields can
be written as
changes in electric and magnetic potentials.
That’s brings our tensor of 16 numbers down
to just a vector with 4.
It contains all the same information and,
honestly, it’s much closer to reality.
Wait a minute!!
Potential is almost potential energy, so I
think we’re onto something here.
We’ve stepped down from the electromagnetic
field to an energy field.
Energy is something quantum particles can
have.
A quantum field is just a field of quantum
properties.
A quantum measurement like energy assigned
to every point in space,
but this is where things get a little wonky.
Quantum properties are intertwined with each
other through the wave function
and, if we imagine that quantum properties
are part of fundamental fields
then they’re no longer attached to particles.
There are 17 different types of particles
with unique properties.
Some of those properties are fixed.
Others, like spin orientation, have some wiggle-room.
If we start treating their properties like
fields instead
then we’re going to need, like, 100s of fields.
So many fields, my brain hurts!
Alright, maybe we can group them together
like we did for the EM field.
Let’s focus on some basic quantum numbers:
Spin, Electric Charge, and Color Charge.
Color charge is how we tell gluons apart
from photons, commenters.
If we group using those properties, the field-count
drops way down.
Different spins and charges require separate
fields, so
we’ve got 6 Leptons, 6 Quarks each with
3 possible color-charges,
8 color-charge combinations for Gluons.
Yep, all separate.
1 Photon, 3 Weak Bosons, and 1 Higgs.
If each one gets its own field, that’s a
grand total of 37 fields,
which is the best we can do without a semester-long
course in particle physics.
Wait, then what’s a particle?
Perfect timing!
You’re, like, my best clone ever.
I’m so proud of you.
Really?!
So these fields exist everywhere, across all
space and time.
But that doesn’t mean particles are everywhere.
There’s only a particle when a quantum field
get excited.
For example, this is the photon field with
no photons in sight.
Here in empty space, the field-energy hovers
around zero
with just some quantum uncertainty keeping
it from being exactly zero.
It’s called the Vacuum State: The ground
state of the field.
Suddenly, an electron and a positron crash
into each other.
They annihilate and their energy is added
to the photon field.
The result is two photons, two non-zero places
in the photon field.
But then, the same can be said about the electron
and positron.
They were just places in the electron field
with an energy hovering above zero
and their interaction shoved their energy
into a different field: The photon field.
It’s just energy moving from one field to
another.
Welcome to Quantum Electrodynamics:
The study of how the electron field and the
photon field interact.
It’s an example of something called a Quantum
Field Theory.
A model that governs how quantum fields interact.
So to summarize:
A quantum field is a set of quantum properties
assigned to every point in space.
Each one existing alongside the others, allowing
them to interact.
and any energy in a field higher than its
vacuum state
will be seen as a particle carrying the properties
of that field.
Whoa!
As usual, if you have any questions, please
ask in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s okay
to be a little crazy.
If you’re like me and you like learning
new skills and also like online video,
you might want to try out SkillShare.
There are over 17,000 video courses available
for aspiring creators
including many on animating in After Effects,
the software I use in my own videos.
If you want to learn how to make animations
as cool-looking as the ones in this video,
you might want to check out:
“The Ultimate Guide to Shape Layers in After
Effects” by Jake Bartlett.
Shape layers are extremely powerful tools
in After Effects if you know how to use them.
Techniques I learned from the ultimate guide
to shape layers made my fancy particle chart
possible.
An annual membership to SkillShare is less
than $10 a month,
But if you sign-up in January 2018 using the
link in the doobly-doo, you’ll get three
months for 99 cents.
So check that out if you’re interested.
By the way, I meant it when I said photons
don’t experience space or time.
In our frame of reference they do, of course,
but they don’t in their own.
For a photon, all of space is one point and
all of time is one moment.
And, on that note, thanks for watching!